be warned this is what happens when you
eat too many skittles or sprinkles or
maybe adult brownies or even better all
three at once
this is the ocean's majestic comb jelly
you think that those rippling bands of
colors would be a case of
bioluminescence which so many sea
creatures deploy but in reality this has
more to do with the critters locomotion
like jellyfish comb jellies are squishy
and lack of brain though they do have a
nervous system and sensors for
orientation but they get around a bit
differently than jellyfish and that's
where the light show comes in
while jellyfish swim with those famous
full-body contractions the comb jelly
moves around with special fluttering
hairs called cilia when white light hits
these filaments gets broken out into its
different colors
hence the I've eaten way too many
skittles effect
but oddly enough this probably never
happens with regular old light from the
Sun scientists have to hit them with
beams from submersibles in order to get
the shimmering comb jellies have
tentacles just like true jellyfish but
their's are sticky as opposed to
stinging depending on the species some
will dangle long lines to snag food
including tiny plankton others have
smaller tentacles around their mouths to
catch prey like the world's most badass
beard yeah you heard me Chuck Norris and
still others have cilia that are
modified into serrated teeth these
species eat other jellies using their
chompers to Ratchet themselves over
their victims think of comb jellies at
the spiders of the sea arachnids have
all kinds of strategies for hunting from
those with classic webs to the trapdoor
spider which ambushes its prey from a
den comb jellies are diverse like that
only they can swim real good and they
look like they're made out of rainbows
and happiness kind of like me
you